- [Interviewer] Kimberley,
where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Kimberley] I was adopted in the Valley.
- [Interviewer] And you grew
up with both your parents?
- Yes, they divorced when I was five.
- [Interviewer] When you
were five they split up?
And did you stayed with mom or dad?
- Mostly with mom, but dad too.
- [Interviewer] And
how was your childhood?
- Perfectly fine.
- [Interviewer] Everything was cool?
- I accepted everything.
- [Interviewer] Were there
any issues, any problems?
- I covered up with
doing sports and chores.
- [Interviewer] What did you cover up?
- Everything that's in my head and mid
and I couldn't explain it.
All the abuse and stuff.
- [Interviewer] It's a
common story down here.
- But it's okay.
- [Interviewer] What kind of abuse?
Sexual, or physical, or?
- [Interviewer] Everything in one.
I don't wanna tell the truth,
but I need to tell it truth.
- [Interviewer] Who is it
from your dad or someone else?
- It is a both, and one more.
I don't know...
- [Interviewer] So there was
sexual abuse in some way?
- Mmh hmm.
- [Interviewer] At what age?
You don't remember?
Was it ongoing?
- Mmh hmm.
May I have some drugs?
Can I do some drugs please?
- [Interviewer] (laughs)
which drug you wanna do?
- Can I go get it?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you have
to go somewhere and get it?
- No, you have a Pookie pipe?
- [Interviewer] I don't
have a Pookie pipe.
- That's the only drug I
have with me right now.
- [Interviewer] We'll
be done in five minutes.
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] All right, so-
- [Kimberley] I shitted and pissed myself
and turned deaf yesterday,
and threw up at the same time.
- [Interviewer] From what?
- Someone drugged me or
someone did something to me.
Or I ate something, I don't know,
but I did everything at once-
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- [Kimberley] And I survived it,
and I'm not trying to lie no
more, trying to tell the truth.
They try to cover up all the bullshit
they put me through here
without feeling like I'm a cop.
So I don't wanna turn to the other side,
or turn the other side,
I just wanna do me.
- [Interviewer] How many years
have you been down here at Skid Row?
- [Kimberley] Three.
- [Interviewer] Three years.
- [Kimberley] Five years.
In SRO, two years in SRO,
three years on the street in tent.
- [Interviewer] I got it.
And what's your drug you're using now?
- [Kimberley] Nothing but
everything in some ways
it depends on the month and a week.
- [Interviewer] What's your
favorite drug right now?
- [Kimberley] Shroom, I
would love to have shroom
'cause I feel like that's gonna help me,
and I'm focused and I can do everything
perfectly fine with it.
- [Interviewer] When you use shroom?
- Yes, it makes me powerful.
It makes me go, just makes
me complete my missions.
It's makes me feel good.
It makes me cover up
all my other drug stuff
and makes me not cry.
- [Interviewer] Does it help you forget
about your pain or your
past or anything like that?
- Yes, sometimes.
Yeah, I guess I just feel powerful.
- [Interviewer] When you use PCP?
- Mmh hmm.
- [Interviewer] How do
you use PCP, you smoke it?
- Smoke it, but I'm good with numbers.
I'm very good, I have
a talent with numbers.
And if I just do it right with the syringe
or measure it right,
I operate perfectly fine.
And everyone's trying to stop me
because I know I'm doing something right.
But I feel like I have two people
and sometimes three in me,
and I try to do the same thing.
And once I know English,
but I understand Spanish.
I'm just trying to do the right thing.
- [Interviewer] Do you have children?
- One.
- [Interviewer] You have what child?
- A son.
- [Interviewer] A son.
Are you raising him or?
- Nope, I made sure he's perfectly
fine with a great family.
- [Interviewer] Who's he with?
- A family friend.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- Which he is happy and perfect.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
That's better than being
out here in the street.
- Oh yeah, Joe John.
- [Interviewer] Do you talk to him?
- Mmh mmh.
- [Interviewer] No.
- Not until I live my life right.
- [Interviewer] And what
do you do for money now?
- EBT, or try to do
errands for people, hustle.
The best way I use is to
try to help people with medication.
I'm not trying to go
any further than that.
- [Interviewer] I mean, a
lot of girls are doing it
by dating guys on the street-
- And thank God I haven't done that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
And where is-
- I'm not no hoe or booster?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- I don't go to stores and steal,
I don't go in cars and homes,
and I'm proud of it, I kept my promise,
and I'm keeping it.
- [Interviewer] Do you have
contact with your family still?
- Somewhat.
- [Interviewer] When's the last time
you spoke to your mum or-
- A month ago.
Those are adoption parents,
but now I know the truth.
I'm just trying to meet
and try to find my family,
my biological mother and father.
- [Interviewer] Have you ever known them?
- Mmh mmh, but I feel like I'm close.
- [Interviewer] So you were
put up for adoption at birth?
- Foster home, my mom said
foster home for two years.
- [Interviewer] And
then you found a family?
- Mmh hmm.
I'm trying not to cry.
- [Interviewer] It's okay.
- I'm just a number.
- [Interviewer] Does your son
know that he's adopted or-
- Uh uh.
- [Interviewer] He thinks his
with his real family and that's that?
- Mmh hmm.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have brothers and sisters?
- Yep.
- [Interviewer] Do you ever talk to them?
- Here and there.
Recently I've been stabbed last year
and then I got closer
to my (burps) family,
excuse me.
- [Interviewer] Does your family know
that you're out here on the street?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And are
they concerned for you?
Do they try to get you?
- They try to, but I
tried to do it by myself
so I don't give them more stress,
even though what they did to me.
I just try and do me.
- Yeah.
'Cause I'm strong.
- [Interviewer] Is this the lowest point
of your life right now or is there-
- I've been waiting lower, but yes, the...
- [Interviewer] When were
times even worse than this?
- Almost then.
And I know stuff, I know things,
and I knows I'm almost towards the end
and I'm being strong until
I go to another world.
- [Interviewer] Okay,
well thank you so much
for talking to me.
Be careful out there.
- Of course, I hear it every day.
- [Interviewer] Thanks (indistinct).